put yourself in uncomfortable situations
staying positive i think
people don't realize it takes work
people quit when they don't know why
they're doing it
i just didn't think anybody would ever
hire me because i thought my talent was
just riding the skateboard
so i just always had it in my head that
if i wanted to go do something
i just had to do it myself
how you doing man doing well how are you
i'm great
listen i like starting these now with
either either
take us on a quick tour or show me
something in your space that you've got
a story on
they can tell us a quick personal story
we just got into this house
uh we've been here only six months i'm
trying to think of
what i would have that has a story to it
how about what's what's behind you it's
like a fingerprint what's that painting
oh yeah this my wife got me this it got
me this it's god's fingerprint so it's a
bunch of verses from the bible that make
a fingerprint
wow yeah that's pretty cool right but
like even like look like on my wall
right like this is how new we are uh
like i don't even have pictures yet
in like anything you know you got empty
frames dude
yeah so you know we're we're not all the
way in yet we've been six months we
should be like fully set but
we're not i love it man well last time
we connected it was about a year and a
half ago
um we put the video on youtube it's got
like 60 something thousand views
um and i love i love you
moving from kind of professional athlete
into successful entrepreneur because a
lot of people don't make that transition
super well what's the update like past
year and a half how's it going how's
commune capital
mikey taylor the entrepreneur out these
days okay so
uh the transition is getting easier it
only gets easier which is good
i would say for me the first year was
the hardest
and then the second year was like you
know when you include social media like
it makes it even harder because you have
people that watch you that want to see
you do one thing so
there was that second year was like dude
we're not into this
you know and then finally you start
catching traction and people like hey
you know what i actually kind of like
this and then you still have your
your drop off but i've definitely gotten
to a groove
where uh people know what i'm doing now
and it's kind of like being established
which is nice
uh and then as far as the company goes
uh well but i mean you transition
through this like we had to move fully
digital
uh had to change the experience from
people looking at apartments it was more
on the management side but you don't you
no longer walk units it's all done
virtually so small change ups and then
we'll see
big picture what changes as far as you
know economy goes and what that looks
like for real estate
but uh all in all it's been it's been
good i mean it's exciting and
interesting time to say the least right
how long were you thinking about moving
to entrepreneurship
while you were because your career was
long dude like your career and
that's not just like a flash in the pan
dude i don't want one yeah
how long were you thinking about i don't
know if the skateboarding thing is like
what i want to keep doing before you
make the switch
well it wasn't so much that it was like
when is it going to end
because like skaters we don't ever want
it then we want to do this forever but
we do
like our sponsors give us typically a
three-year contract so that's how long
we think we have
you know to continue to do it and every
time the contract ends it's like
am i getting another one so it was every
three years
and for me it's funny man i think cause
i didn't go to school
and i skateboarded i i just didn't think
anybody would ever hire me because i
thought my talent was just riding a
skateboard
so i just always had it in my head that
if i wanted to go do something
i just had to do it myself which is a
weird way to look at it but it ended up
leading towards
entrepreneurship and how did you get
over the
i mean i'm just a skater i didn't go to
school i'm gonna i'm gonna now
buy apartment buildings and raise funds
like that's a shift dude
dude i started small it's like i started
with companies inside of skateboarding
in the world i knew
and there were you know a handful of
guys that i got to look up to
as an example that own their own
skateboard companies
and like that was i don't know it felt
like an easier transition because it was
all skaters that were owning them
so i started there and then you know
that led into trying to get outside of
kind of our world and then with what i
do now
it was hard because i was like i was
sitting at tables and like i didn't know
the language
i looked completely different like there
was definitely this insecurity that came
over me like am i even supposed to be
here
and then you just like start gaining
confidence in yourself that yeah you can
be here
you're just packed to get your was
different but i mean dude it was just
time i just had to keep going through it
and
and become comfortable in it and what
keeps the motivation because a lot of
people get into that boardroom and then
they realize oh my god this is
a different this is a different language
i don't know what i'm doing here like
why not quit
when most people do i think people quit
when they don't know why they're doing
it
you know and for me the why was so
important that
the the challenge was fine because i
didn't want to stop until i accomplished
it
so i think it's just it you know my
purpose was there
which then became my motivation through
hard times
i love it okay well since we're live how
about we throw into some questions too
from the audience you down for that
let's do it how to stay positive
you want me to answer that one yeah go
for it go for it uh
so staying positive i think people don't
realize it takes work
it's not something that's easy to
maintain at all times
and the thing that i found that really
helps is how i start my morning
helps me maintain a better attitude
throughout the day
and anytime i start and i kind of spend
time being
appreciative of what i have being
thankful it puts me in a better mood
throughout the day to stay positive
because you're you're thankful for
things instead of complaining about what
you don't have
and whatever you're focusing on you
obsess over so if you obsess over the
good
it helps you stay in a good mentality if
you focus on the bad that's when
you have the challenge of being negative
all day i think
i think i mean just doing work that you
love right like when you woke up today
and you're you're fired up for it it's
easy to stay positive i guess i got
mikey taylor in my calendar today let's
go man come on now
100 you put me in like accounting or
something i'm gonna just
i'm gonna hate my life a hundred percent
you know what man i i
i the more and more i kind of do this
the more i lean on purpose
when you have your purpose set when you
know what your purpose is
uh the i guess pursuit of happiness
becomes
easier or it's easier to stay in it what
would you put down as as your purpose
so i think there's three actually
components you have to answer before you
can figure out how to be happy and it's
identity purpose and destiny
who are you why are you here and where
do we go
after this and you know if
if we're talking about identity and that
was the challenge for me when
skateboarding left because skateboarding
was my identity
uh identity now i view as
uh i am mikey taylor the father husband
and person and what i'm doing at the
moment is just what i'm doing but it is
not who i
am uh my purpose i believe is to
live a life that glorifies god in
anything i do
uh and so with that it
it's very simple it's okay now i'm on
i'm doing this company this is real
estate everybody i work with it needs to
be done in a positive loving way anybody
on social media
i i hold myself or try to hold myself to
an example that
is good and so in that even through
tough times it makes it easy
i guess for me to go okay this sucks i
want to be pissed off i want to act bad
well how
is my response is that going to glorify
god and if it's not
that's probably not the response and
then that actually ends up putting me
in more of a happy mentality or happy
mood
so so the thumbprint behind you is a
good reminder
of the purpose super good reminder 100
because i i struggled with that before i
mean when skateboarding ended i felt
like i lost everything i didn't do
purpose all
right and that was the most miserable
i've ever been in my life and
so even with all the techniques of
trying to be happy i couldn't be happy
so i had to like fall back on the
principles of like what am i doing here
what am i supposed to do here
you know and then you start once you
know your purpose then you you're able
to
gauge if you're even doing it correctly
or not if you don't know why you're here
how do you engage if you're doing a good
job
you can next one popping up i want to be
an entrepreneur but don't know
what i should pick as my niche any
suggestions
that's a good question uh so for me
uh i am more of a passion person like i
can't get into things i don't like
so i try to find things that i'm
interested in and then figure out a way
to build something around that i think
that just came from
skateboarding uh but with that said i
don't
because i'm like that i don't know how
to master oh i'm gonna go do this
and then figure out how to like it i
have to wait for it to hit me and
there's kind of some challenge in that
but i think actually i could be able to
answer that better than me it's not even
that far off dude like i think you make
the big decisions with your heart and
the small ones with your head
like i think a lot of people are are
just too looking at how do i go make
money
and if you don't love the thing you're
gonna get crushed yeah
i like that well said right like if
you're going up against people who love
the thing like if skateboarding is a
strategy because it's hot
and you're going to go up against mikey
taylor and people who i like
loved it right or getting into real
estate and mikey taylor loves it and you
just think it's a strategy
and all the due diligence and all the
research that you're putting in to find
the deals and the amount of hours
to actually find a good opportunity
right
did you just didn't get crushed if you
could love it it's a really good point
like look starting a company is brutal
it is not easy it is so hard it's
exhausting
it's challenging and if you it's like
the question you asked earlier if you
don't love it you're gonna
be broke you're not gonna not in a
monetary standpoint you're just gonna be
broken down it's like
you won't be able to fight through the
times where it feels like the walls are
closed again
unless you love what you're trying to do
so i think that's a phenomenal answer
yeah i mean you just you got to love it
first and then you have to tie it to how
can you bring value to other people
that's right right that's how you start
wanting so there's
more than like what what business trying
to start right now i mean you gotta you
gotta actually love it
how do you recover from a painful
situation um that's a good question
physically or mentally or both
i don't know take it where you want go
go mentally because physically
we kind of know the mental ones are the
hard ones so
this is the encouragement to it when you
go through a
painful situation you're being
challenged i think we
we automatically try to stay away from
pain because we think pain
equals something bad but pain
is good for us because if we recognize
what our
limits are or that we can actually take
our limits to the further
further place so in any painful
situation i look at it as a time to
improve uh and then every time i've gone
through those situations on the other
end
i've actually come out better so in hard
times i just focus on what's gonna
happen not
the feeling i have right now uh but it's
not easy
i think it depends on what you're
dealing with um but
i guess simply put time heals everything
so just hang on to where you're going to
go after
the initial moment i think service too
right like
whatever you've struggled with you could
then help other people through
and your purpose comes from your pain so
if you could think about hey i'm going
to get through this
in a couple years or five years or six
months or whatever and then i'm going to
make sure
nobody else has to deal with the same
emotional trauma
right i think i think of candace
lightner you know candice leitner
no she started um so she was a real
estate agent
a mother of like three kids um single
mom real estate agent
and then her her 13 year old daughter
got hit by a drunk driver
and like died on the spot like was flown
you know
you know feet forward um and just died
and she became so enraged they caught
the driver
and the police said he's done this
before
he's just he was drunk he's not gonna
the laws aren't
in our side and he's probably going to
walk again and she got so pissed
that she she uh started mothers against
drunk driving
so she took that like crazy pain of
losing a child to a drunk driver and
knowing that he was going to walk
out of it yeah like no other i don't
want any other mob to have to face the
same thing that i struggled with
and launched mothers against drunk
driving right so like that that pain can
define you
in a negative way for most people or for
some in a positive way to say
nobody else like through service nobody
else now will have to suffer the same
way that i suffered
that's well said i love that that's
really well said is it easy to balance
work life and family life oh
the new dad here in the house he's
welcome we didn't say congratulations
too by the way
thank you i appreciate that uh so
for me it is incredibly hard it is
really really hard it's one of
my life and my biggest struggles
is i am an obsessive personality and
when i do things it consumes me
and that is not a good uh quality when
it comes to
having a wife or a husband so uh
for me i just have to really really
really work on it i have to set
reminders
uh and it's hard i i wish i had an
answer
for you on how to make it simple but for
me it's not it's
uh it's an everyday struggle the only
good i found
uh in making the situation better is
putting time on the calendar to spend
with my wife and with my kids so just
making it i guess schedule
for me uh but no it is so hard for me i
don't know how it is for you evan but it
is
hard for me here's the thing like we we
tend to schedule
our business stuff but we don't schedule
our
other stuff our personal stuff our
relationships so
i schedule stuff into and which i treat
it as important as like if i'm going to
cancel on my wife on something
it's like i'm canceling on this to say
hey mark you can't do it like you treat
it as important
yeah um one of the things my wife and i
did is
we try to figure out how can we have fun
every morning so instead of just like
wake up and do
be productive what would make it fun
every morning
so we'll do uh a 10 minute meditation
together and then go outside
and take the dogs and just have fun like
that's 9 30
every morning we're doing that before i
come in and start doing interviews and
everything else
um because it was just bang bang and
like weekends and evenings we'd have
together but how can we start the day
doing something fun so yeah i agree i
mean how old is your your little guy now
our little guy is about three and a half
months our middle is
five our oldest is eight yeah and when
you start having kids it's even harder
to spend time with your wife or husband
so
what we're on which really helps we do a
a weekly date so every week we go on a
date and just have like
alone time with us but uh yeah man
that is a that's a struggle of mine 100
you schedule it in the same thing like
friday night i end at five
whatever i'm doing to sit down at the
table have have dinner with my wife
so i will say this that's been one huge
blessing for us through this
little kova thing is kind of
re-establishing the importance of all of
us eating together at the dinner table
uh that's been huge and so that one's
one that uh i don't think we're gonna
let go after this
like guys every night we're all here
we're gonna eat no
phones conversation that's been a big
plus for us
what else are you gonna not let go of i
mean obviously you want to be around
people and get back out to it but
oh man uh let's see
i'll probably work from home a little
bit more than i used to i
you know i was in the office uh pretty
much
five days a week unless i was out
meeting with people i'll probably switch
it up and go
three days here two days at the office
just because i do like the idea of still
being able to see the kids while i'm
working
stuff like that i'll hang on to that
we'll do the dinner time
uh and what i would like to hang on to
is like i don't know if anyone else is
watching this has experienced this but
through lockdown
dude we are spending way less money like
there are so many things that we are not
doing and
you know kind of that's been a plus but
my concern is once
you know this thing opens up it's i love
going out like dude we love going out to
dinner we love seeing people
and that adds up so uh we'll see if
there's a
a new balance we can create there cool
man well i remember even between
when we had uh our chat last year or a
year and a half ago
you were in your car like between
meetings and just pulled over
because it was time and you didn't make
it back on time when i talked to you
last is in the middle of the capital
race
and it was like i would do it was going
from person to person to person
and i didn't get home for our thing i
remember i stopped in the parking lot
i'm like hey
i'm so sorry i'm sitting in my car yeah
he's hustling
yes from the entrepreneur how
to get excitement back to your life oh
man okay i think if you're not
excited you're maybe not challenging
yourself
the way you should uh so i don't know
what helps me is like i try to just do
something that
i'm like it's hard like that improvement
is exciting for me
it feels makes me feel fulfilled and
that i'm getting better
so you know it doesn't have to
necessarily be in business just pick
something that's just
insane uh set a goal and then work at
your goal and i think that
will help bring excitement i think just
like just trying stuff just say yes
well yeah a hundred percent put yours
yeah put yourself in uncomfortable
situations
but like i think people expect to be
great
the first time up and then they're not
great and then they quit
anybody who doesn't golf try golfing
battle
that is it's so hard that if you want a
good challenge man that's
that's one for sure just expect to suck
and just go have fun with it and see
like i think it's like going on a date
and expecting to get married after the
first date
like the goal is do i want to have a
second date so you get an idea
you try it expect to suck and just see
do you did it give you the excitement
you were looking for it if you had go do
it again and if not go find something
else
like you won't find it sitting on the
couch at home that's right
you guys that's right yep that's right
love the process right not the outcome
ben schmidt's asking do you sell
properties or do you own rental
properties
i get real estate now yeah so we're
we're uh
we are a real estate fund so we have
investors come in we
buy either existing apartments or
some type of asset that we can repurpose
into apartments do the work and then we
hold them so we own rental properties
what's next for comm you know are you
trying to raise more are you still
looking for investors are you
on a slow point now because of real
estate or what
so what's so this is the this has been
the hardest part about what i'm doing
is uh the regulations from the sec
and how strict they are who can invest
in who can't and so
right now we can only have accredited
investors which
for those who don't know you either have
to make 200 000 a year
if you're married you need to make 300
000 a year or have a net worth of a
million
and my purpose was not to make the rich
more money my purpose was to bring as
many people as possible
to achieve financial freedom and me
coming from the skate world we didn't
make money like that like
pro skateboarders aren't baseball
players we didn't even make close to
millions so
that's been a big struggle of getting to
the point of allowing
everyone to invest we are finally there
now
and starting to go through the process
of what's called a reg a
plus offering which removes the
accreditation process
or the accreditation requirement so once
we get filed we go through the sec
process of approval uh that is going to
be a whole new world for me because now
it'll go
more on social media and trying to get
as many people involved instead of the
i think right now we're at about 60
investors so it's a it's a small few
it's
now this is aligning with my true
purpose yeah nice dude i mean that
that was the problem a year and a half
ago was the same thing
that's right it's and it's like dude i'm
so much on like
you know not only investing in
opportunity but we do a lot of education
as well i want people to understand how
money works
and so you know when you use social
media to get out to that many people
and and the majority of people are
first-time investors it's like where do
i start
and then i go well you can go over there
and go over there but i would love to go
hey you know what
come be involved with us it it's uh it
opens it up to where
i want this thing to truly head so
what's the minimum going to be
and when is that going to launch so our
minimum right now
is a hundred thousand dollars that
minimum will come down to
where we're at right now i think about
five thousand dollars uh
the sec gives you kind of a broad stroke
on timeline of approval they say
anywhere between three and twelve months
so
once it gets filed uh we'll see when
they approve but we're hoping
uh sometime right around the end of year
beginning of uh first quarter
nice dude i mean yes has things slowed
down because of corona
yes and no from a work standpoint no
it's been
so busy uh from closing on buildings or
apartments
that's been the challenge it's just real
estate's good because it's slow
right it doesn't react like the stock
market corona hits stock market plummets
real estate just does this
but when a correction needs to happen
sellers are typically slow
to adjust so we're underwriting a ton of
properties we're putting in
a lot of lois but sellers are not
selling
they're bringing buildings off market uh
and then now we're finally starting to
see
buildings come back on market for the
second time which means you're starting
to see a price correction
so we're waiting for for sellers to get
there we don't want to catch a falling
knife
you know we want some type of reduction
in uncertainty
so what that means is we're doing a lot
of work
deal flow is a challenge but investor uh
excitement is at an all-time high if
people know that there's opportunity in
front of us
uh it's just waiting for the right
opportunity essentially
i love it man yeah well i want to be
conscious of the time
um mikey taylor in the house for people
who want to dive into
your world commune uh obviously people
watching live but youtube will link
stuff up below where do you want them to
go
uh if you get to my instagram uh you can
pretty much get
anywhere from there i have my number and
my instagram you can shoot me a text
i respond to as many people as possible
but the the list is getting a little bit
long so i'm slow
so if you text me on monday it might
take until friday to get back to you but
that's a good good place for sure all
right at mikey taylor we'll link that up
below too
dude good to see you glad everybody's
safe and healthy and happy and um
i'm pumped to continue to watch your
entrepreneurial journey explode
brother has a blessing all right much
love if you want to change your life for
the next 30 days check the link below me
and if you want to see my last interview
with mikey taylor it was awesome
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there